mais d'abord le président de la
république a choisi tour pour sa
première sortie officielle en 2021
le chef de l'état s'est rendu à la
caisse d'allocations familiales
objectif lancer sa réforme des pensions
alimentaires visite sous le sceau du
social donc est sous haute sécurité dans
un contexte économique et sanitaire
tendue sur place on retrouve romain des
piles
qu'est ce qui signale une visite des
manuels macron à la caf de tours
tout d'abord le large périmètre autour
du centre administratif du chant giro et
de la gare ensuite des forces de l'ordre
en nombre stationné devant la gare car
enfin une manifestation était organisée
ce matin place jean jaurès sur place une
centaine de personnes des syndicalistes
quelques gilet jaune et des blouses
blanches celles qui se sont appelés les
oubliés du ségur de la santé par rapport
à une injustice salariale qui n'est pas
légal puisque dans les textes de loi on
dit à travail égal salaire égal et dans
notre structure là où on travaille on
accueille des patients et des résidents
de psychiatrie qui ont un statut
administratif de différent le fus
qu'emmanuel mâcon viennent et qui est
une manifestation du coup c'était aussi
pour nous l'occasion de se faire
entendre aussi sur cette injustice
salariale le président de la république
lui est arrivé à 14h40 à la caf par la
rue marcel tribut
l'objet de sa visite c'est la création
d'une sorte de service public des
pensions alimentaires et moi en un mot
pour vous dire je dois dire découvert la
profondeur et la gravité du sujet qui
nous touchent et dont on va parler
aujourd'hui on me demande ce qu'on a pu
la crise des gilets jaunes et du grand
débat qui s'en est suivi un dispositif
ouvert depuis le mois d'octobre au
parent séparé et qui ont des problèmes
d'impayés
pendant une heure emmanuel macron s'est
entretenu avec quelques bénéficiaires de
touraine
un garçon de huit ans maintenant je mets
les papas qui veulent pas payer
enfin je veux dire on n'a aucune
solution et puis derrière ça
aussi l'impression demander la charité
quand on demande la pension alimentaire
alors que c'est pas le cas je veux dire
quelque part c'est c'est un droit et
est un droit pour l'enfant suite aux
mesures imposées sur le territoire aucun
politique n'a accompagné emmanuel macron
durant sa visite à la caf
dans l'après-midi un rendez vous était
organisée avec quelques élus de touraine
à la préfecture